- See, Collectivists see
the State as the source
of our morals, and our
families as obstacles
standing between individuals
and their master.
That's exactly what's
happening with Alfie Evans,
where bureaucrats are standing
between parents and their child,
saying that they know best
that a child has to die,
because they know better
than the parents do.
Collectivists,
there's a reason that Karl Marx abhorred
the traditional family,
let's just say that.
He saw it as a Capitalist institution
based on capital and on private gain.
He openly called for
abolition of the family.
There's a reason Stalin
trained Soviet youth
to become pioneers, that's
what he called them,
emissaries of the State who were told
that the highest good involves
ratting out your own family members.
At 1932 Soviet trial, a
father actually cried out
to his son, "It's me, your father,"
and the son replied, "Yes,
he used to be my father,
but I no longer consider him my father.
I'm not acting as a
son, but as a pioneer."
Stalin used to go around Soviet Russia
talking about this story, and using it
as an example of good behavior.
Hey, breaking down the family
is a precondition to
building up the State.